from the binary digits that computers
use to represent data to the most
sophisticated artificial intelligence
programs logic is key to the development
and implementation of the technologies
we use daily
however logic isn't just a tool for
programmers to develop fancy software we
all use logical reasoning on a regular
basis to think through problems and make
decisions
there are a lot of advantages to
burnishing your logic skills
if you're learning a code practicing
logical reasoning will help you
understand how programming languages
work and how programmers use them to
solve problems if you're not into
software development then learning
logical reasoning will make you a more
effective and self-aware thinker and
that has applications far beyond
programming
today i would like to explore the topic
of logical reasoning covering the
following areas what is logical
reasoning why it's important in the
context of programming and how you can
start learning it narrowly defined
logical reasoning is the practice of
applying induction deduction or another
logical method to a problem
more broadly using logical reasoning
means analyzing the relationships among
the constituent parts of an argument or
process it involves thinking about how
elements interact to bring about a
certain result
logical reasoning has tons of practical
applications
you can use it to construct strong
arguments and analyze the arguments of
others you can use it to develop
step-based processes that are efficient
effective and internally coherent
this is why logical reasoning is so
important to so many disciplines
philosophers scientists mathematicians
and computer programmers all use logic
in their work
there are many types of logical
reasoning let's discuss two of the most
important ones before exploring the role
of logical reasoning in programming
i am specifically referring to the
inductive and deductive logical
reasoning
inductive reasoning involves evaluating
a body of information to derive a
general conclusion
whenever you engage in research you're
using inductive reasoning as you are
gathering evidence and using it to
better understand the topic at hand
it's important to remember however that
the conclusions you'll arrive at through
induction will often be built on
evidence that is incomplete
this means that the outcome of inductive
reasoning tends to be probable rather
than certain
deductive reasoning is the process of
deriving conclusions from principles
called premises the syllogism is one of
the most basic forms of deductive
reasoning
a syllogism includes a major premise a
minor premise and a conclusion in
syllogisms we are given a set of
conditions and we have to check whether
the conclusions given after the
conditions are true or not for these
types of questions the best way is to
consider all cases in draw venn diagrams
even if we can find one venn diagram
such that a conclusion gets false that
conclusion is the wrong choice
let's explore an example
imagine you were given the following
information
all rockets are poles some poles are
trams some trams are ropes all ropes are
tense
also you are given the following
conclusions
conclusion one some tents are trams
conclusion two some ropes are rockets
conclusion 3 some trams are rockets
conclusion 4 some poles are rockets in
order to derive the solution i am going
to draw the venn diagram based on the
provided information
as you can see only conclusion 1 and
conclusion four are true
another way programmers use their
logical reasoning is when they create
algorithms the data science machine
learning and artificial intelligence
programs especially rely on
sophisticated algorithms which cannot be
created without applying proper logical
methods
you see an algorithm is a set of
instructions that tells a program what
to do on the basis of certain inputs a
simple decision tree algorithm for
instance will consist of a series of
branching decisions the logic of each
branch is fairly simple if a certain
condition is met do i if not do b
these branching decisions are repeated
through later stages of the program to
specify the appropriate end result based
on the inputs now that i've briefly
covered the main applications of the
logical reasoning and programming let me
share some of the ways you can become a
better thinker and therefore a better
programmer first find a news article in
a reputable publication read it and try
to pick out the author's primary claim
then try to identify the pieces of
evidence that the author uses to support
that claim
does the author's claim follow logically
from the evidence or does the claim go
beyond what the evidence actually
supports
analyzing how authors use evidence to
support their arguments is a great way
of practicing inductive reasoning second
next time you're planning how to tackle
a new project break your process down
into steps and then write them down on a
piece of paper does the end result
follow logically from the steps that
preceded or does the process contain
steps that are redundant unnecessary or
counterproductive third spend time on
creative hobbies
it turns out that creative outlets like
drawing painting writing and playing
music can stimulate the brain and help
promote logical thinking
creative thinking naturally develops
problem-solving abilities that can help
you become a better performer at work
learning a new instrument for example
requires deep thought and concentration
the logical thinking skills you'll gain
from this process can help you approach
your work more intently developing your
ability to solve more problems with
flexibility and ease
in addition creative hobbies help reduce
stress
when your stress levels are manageable
you will likely have an easier time
focusing in making logical decisions you
can handle stress in many different ways
but developing your creative mind is
especially productive and can bolster
both your personal and professional life
fourth practice questioning
one of the best ways to strengthen your
logical thinking skills is to ask
questions about things you typically
accept as fact
regularly asking questions helps you
view situations more completely allowing
you to approach problems that work more
logically and creatively
asking questions can also often lead to
discoveries about topics you had not
considered before which may encourage
you to explore further you can use this
method anywhere especially at work
consider a department at your workplace
you are not familiar with and create a
list of questions that will help you
understand its purpose
for example if you want to know more
about search engine optimization
consider asking someone in that
department for a short informational
interview to learn more about their
current projects and processes this can
help you think more critically about
your role at work as it relates to that
team finally try to anticipate the
outcomes of your decisions
when working to strengthen your logical
thinking skills it is helpful to
consider what impact your decisions
might have in the future
the closer you pay attention to the
results of your decisions the easier the
process will become
when you come up with a solution to a
problem at work try to think about what
the outcome may be
eventually you will find it easier to
think of the immediate and long-term
results of your decisions which is an
important aspect of logical thinking
logic skills can be easily strengthened
with daily practice when you apply these
exercises regularly you will start to
naturally approach everyday decisions at
work with a more logical perspective
if you found this video useful i'd
appreciate if you smash the like button
and click on the notification bell
also make sure to subscribe to the
coding tech channel for more videos like
this in the future